j'accueille maintenant un grand ami de
laurent gerra c'est pierre bellemare
comment ça va ça m'a bien vous
connaissez tous le monde
harlem désir oui oui bien sûr marion
cotillard taxi un taxi depuis d'autres
choses
richard anconina six pack vous
connaissez et laurent gerra qu'on
voulait vendre plus sur tout à vous j'ai
raconté défense et wuhan à alphen il
parle déjà
bon alors vous présentait sur france 3
les bêtises de monsieur pierre oui
produit par nagui
oui et de nîmes a senti voilà et ça
marche vachement bien ça fonctionne ça
fait 25 % de parts de marché sur une
chaîne dont la moyenne et 18
donc on ne peux que vous féliciter oui
mais ce contexte rien c'est la
recrudescence pas compte de ce système
oui toutes les chaînes sans exception
fondé des émissions de bêtises moi je
pense pas de vieux bouts de film c'est
un peu la télévision de faire ailleurs
maintenant et tout à fait normaux ce
qu'on fait c'est qu'on prépare pour
arthur dans le dix ans on fait des trucs
ici qui pourra utiliser dans dix ans on
est sympa on travaille pour lui bon
alors vous êtes là pas pour parler des
bêtises de monsieur pierre qu'on regarde
régulièrement aux états pour parler d'un
livre
empreinte de la bête oui fonction lampe
and de la bête chez albin michel genêt
crise avec jean-marc epinoux et
jean-françois namias absolument c'est 50
histoires où l'animal a le premier rôle
vient alors eu donc vous avez votre
première émission de télé achat en 87 et
vous quel effet la première émission de
télé achat en 87
oui en france oui cet honneur le 5
octobre 1996 j'ai vendu je peux vous
dire que j'ai vendu dirigé mardi il y
avait il y avait du jeu oui on a cru un
oeuf d'autruche assure un petit sac
voilà il y avait un service de couteau
oui laguiole il y avait une lampe à
pétrole qui ressemble à une grosse loupe
et qui avec une mèche en fibre de verre
inusable oui cet effet par des haies des
souffleurs de verre américain oui oui
c'est vrai artisan americas ne devez pas
de latrines et ben on se souvient
particulièrement parce que vous voulez
garder parce que ces objets c'était oui
j'ai chez moi la loupe j'ai chez moi 9
absolument j'ai acheté un nom un
incroyable d'objets hotelia ça promet je
précise toujours compris hein parce que
de la pire des choses quand on est
commerçant vous le savez c'est de céder
aux avances et qui sont toujours temps
de dire je peux vous faire un prix très
intéressant
là vous êtes foutu parce qu'évidemment
forcément vous construisez moi je trouve
ça formidable jusqu'au jour où j'ai vu
le spectacle durant la semaine
c'est bien je veux parodie très bien
magnéto serge